[Musique]
selon la religion chrétienne dieu s'est
incarné sur terre en y dépêchant son
fils jésus-christ
pendant plusieurs années en palestine
romaine jésus-christ a enseigné aux
hommes sa doctrine il a fondé une ère
nouvelle l'ère chrétienne et un clergé
pour assurer la relève de sa mission
l'église
cette venue du sauveur avait été annoncé
depuis longtemps dans un livre sacré
l'ancien testament
mais en parallèle main peuples païens a
aussi reçu la divine connaissances
notamment les celtes
jadis les druides ont en effet on saigne
et l'espérance en un divine enfants de
lumière née d'une femme vierge
et si les soldes avaient attendu le
christ et l'avaient reconnu
la philosophie est une discipline de
l'esprit dans laquelle excellent les
anciens grecs tel platon ou aristote
elle consiste à questionner la nature et
à chercher la vérité sur le monde et
l'homme
se savoir devant aboutir à la sagesse
mais d'où vient la philosophie qui l'a
inventé de quel peuple provient-elle
selon diogène laërce un auteur grec du
3ème siècle de notre ère la philosophie
aurait vu le jour chez les perses les
assyriens les hindous voir chez les
celtes
quelques indices que l'étude de la
philosophie a commencé chez les barbares
kelly n'est des matches et les perses
des chaldéens chez les babyloniens et
assyriens les gino sophistes chez les
hindous et chez les celtes et les
galates de ce qu'on appelle druide ou
sommes notés
parmi les philosophes grecs il en est un
qui retient l'attention des anciens dès
qu'il leur faut saisir la pensée
religieuse des druides ce philosophe
c'est pythagore
établi en italie du sud il est possible
qu'il est eu des contacts avec des
celtes ce qui expliquerait certaines
similitudes
en gaule les droïdes constitue un clergé
loin des affaires du siècle il habite en
communauté et se livre aux études des
choses sacrées
[Musique]
l'historien antique ammien marcellin
passe en revue les différentes
corporations de prêtres qui officient en
gaule
concernant les druides il précise
parmi eux supérieurs en intelligence et
selon la règle de pythagore associés en
communauté fraternelle les druides et
les former aux mystères cachés et hautes
études
enfin méprisant les choses humaines il
proclamait que les âmes sont mortes et
ses communautés deux frères qui se
consacre aux études mystique annonce par
bien des aspects les futurs monastère
d'occident
il n'y a aucune influence étrangère ni
grec ni romaine me juive dans
l'élaboration des futurs congrégation de
l'europe chrétienne mais plutôt la
persistance de vieilles coutumes
celtique
les anciennes confréries de druide sont
devenus socialement parlant les
monastères de l'église catholique
ausy dawnnews de rhodes est un
philosophe et savant grec
néanmoins 135 cet esprit curieux et
intelligents entreprend vert - sans un
voyage en gaule
là il rencontre des intellectuels des
druides avec lesquels il échange des
savoirs et s'instruit de leur
enseignement
à son retour en grèce posidonia ce
produit une oeuvre encyclopédique dont
il ne reste hélas que des extraits des
témoignages rapportés par d'autres
auteurs
posidonia aux semeurs à rome en -51
la même année jules césar qui séjourne à
bibracte en gaule est en train d'écrire
son célèbre livre la guerre des gaules
il est admis que le général romain a
beaucoup puisé dans l'oeuvre de
posidonies hausse
notamment quant à la géographie
l'ethnologie le climat la société et la
religion des druides
les druides enseigne l'immortalité de
l'âme est semble-t-il une certaine forme
de réincarnation
aussi ils devisent sur la nature des
dieux et l'astronomie
le premier point et leur enseignement
c'est que les âmes ne périsse pas mais
qu'après la mort elle pas d'accord dans
un autre de plus les bruits le dit
certes beaucoup sur les attrayant
mouvement sur les dimensions du monde de
la terre sur la nature des choses sur la
force le pouvoir des dieux immortels et
l'enceinte et la jeunesse
la compétence des druides en astronomie
été reconnue par les grecs et les
romains
[Musique]
c'est sans doute de son voyage en gaule
que posidonia a ramené les données d'une
sorte de planétaire
il s'agit d'une sphère armillaire qui
modélise en trois dimensions la voûte
céleste
le philosophe romain cicéron s'en fait
le témoin direct
[Musique]
naguère notre chapeau z/os news a
réalisé une sphère où tous en même temps
et avec leur propre révolution
le soleil la lune et les cinq planètes
et ce qu'il se fait dans le ciel chaque
jour et chaque nuit
au cours de son périple à travers
l'espace et compte tenu de sa propre
rotation sur elle-même la terre mais
environ 2150 ans pour franchir une
constellations du zodiaque
sachant qu'il y a 12 signes du zodiaque
le tour complet de cette formidable
ronde dure près de 26000 ans on
l'appelle la grande année
vu de la terre il s'agit tout simplement
du lent mouvement rétrograde des signes
du zodiaque dans notre ciel on l'appelle
la précession des équinoxes
[Musique]
or la centaine d'années avant notre ère
voit ce opérer un tel changement de
signe zodiacal
on quitte alors l'ère du bélier pour
entrer dans l'ère du poisson
est ce basculement cosmique que guette
certains prêtres dans le vaste monde
tels les druide gaulois où les marges
pers
en attente il la venue d'un héros
céleste parmi les hommes
l'un des premiers symboles que les
chrétiens vont bientôt utilisée pour
représenter le christ sera le poids sont
identiques aux signaux dia cale
désormais montant dans le ciel
le pays des carnutes au coeur de la
gaule s'entend avant notre ère
sur une colline boisée la tribu a
convoqué ces états généraux que préside
le vieux roi nommé priscu ce la sphère
et sérieuse d'après les druides qui ont
ausculté les astres les taux sont
proches pour un bouleversement universel
selon une prophétie celtic en effet une
femme vierge fécondé par un dieu va
enfanter un héros pour le salut du monde
à flanc de colline s'enfonce une grotte
et dans cette grotte 1 puis
devant l'assemblée le roi priscu ce
ordonne d'y placer l'hôtel consacrée à
la vierge
des artisans en façonner une statue de
femme tenant un nourrisson dans ses bras
et contre la statue de cette vierge à
l'enfant on a écrit virginie paris tours
et à la vierge qui doit enfanter
offrant deux des druides guerrier et
gens du peuple à la sainte femme futures
mères du divine enfants
le lieu de cette cérémonie légendaire
est connu c'est la colline de chartres
quant à la grotte de la vierge à
l'enfant elle est devenue la crypte de
la cathédrale notre dame
on y voit en cours le puits druidique
creusé à même la roche calcaire et
rebaptisé puis dessin fort
les bâtisseurs de la cathédrale ont
intégré cet espace payen à l'édifice
chrétiens ainsi l'eau du puits se trouve
à 37 mètres en dessous du sol de la
cathédrale
tandis que la voûte culmine à 37 mètres
de haut
au
coeur du dallage le célèbre labyrinthe
est donc exactement à mi-chemin entre le
ciel divin et les cinq entrailles de la
terre
si l'on admet les 100 ans avant la
naissance du verbe incarné cet hôtel
druidique de chartres serait le plus
ancien sanctuaire au monde en hommage à
la mère du christ
et ans sans enfant leroy pris ce qu'ils
décident de faire don de sa principauté
à la sainte vierge
le chapitre druidique héritent donc des
lieux saints de la colline de chartres
plus de mille ans après ces événements
la cathédrale de chartres
érigé sur les lieux mêmes de cette
révélation mariale aura conservé le
thème de l'incarnation et de la vierge à
l'enfant
le changement officiel de religion non
seulement n'a pas altéré la croyance
celtic en la vierge qui en fera mais il
la confirme
la vieille chronique de l'église de
chartres daté de 13 189 et le plus
anciens textes connus sur le sujet
ladite église avait été fondée avant la
naissance du christ en l'honneur de la
vierge qui doit enfanter et elle était
dirigée par des prêtres payen
ces prêtres payen était évidemment les
druides
c'est même dans cette province des
carnutes c'est à dire entre chartres et
la forêt d'orléans que tous les druides
du pays venaient tenir leur synode
annuel
chaque année à date fixe sur le
territoire des carnutes qui passe pour
le centre de toute la gaule les drills
eux tiennent leur assise en un lieu
consacré
que le principal culte païen à la sainte
vierge soit dans la région même où se
réunissaient jadis les druide gaulois
n'est sans doute pas le fruit du hasard
bientôt royaume et églises joignent leur
autorité pour donner au sanctuaire de
chartres une ancienneté unique au monde
on reconnaît en effet aux druides
d'avoir reçu la grâce du saint-esprit et
d'avoir prophétisé longtemps avant notre
ère la venue du christ et de sa mère
le christianisme se fait ainsi le relais
des prophéties celtique et ce relais a
été actée par les plus hautes signature
en quatorze 132 dans un acte légal le
roi charles vii déclare que la
cathédrale de chartres est le plus
ancien sanctuaire de son royaume et
qu'on y en aurait déjà la vierge mère
avant l'ère chrétienne
l'église de chartres est la plus
ancienne de notre royaume fondée par
prophétie en l'honneur de la glorieuse
vierge mère avant l'incarnation de notre
seigneur jésus-christ et ans à laquelle
s est glorieuse vierge est adoré en son
vivant en 15 117 l'église parachève la
sphère dans une bulle le pape léon
disent confiants que la sainte vierge
était bien honorer sur la colline de
chartres et ce bien avant la naissance
du christ
loin d'être confiné à chartres le culte
de la vierge qui doit enfanter et
nationale un jour près du village de
longpont sur orge dans l'essonne des
bûcherons tombe par hasard sur un arbre
pas comme les autres dans son tronc il
découvre la statue d'une vierge à
l'enfant
prêtres et villageois y voit le signe
que leur propre aïeux ont autrefois
attendu la vierge marie
[Musique]
en ce lieu a depuis été bâtie la
basilique notre dame de bonne garde
cette basilique possède le plus grand
reliquaire de france
selon la légende locale saint-denis
l'apôtre de paris aurait oeuvré ici à la
conversion des druides
quant aux images païenne de la gaule
elle semble confirmer la présence de cet
ancien dames sacré
[Musique]
jadis la ds la plus honorer en gaule et
est epona or la jument divine est
parfois accompagné de son poulain icône
animalière à rapprocher peut-être de la
vierge qui doit en fonte et
[Musique]
l'histoire sainte a ainsi plusieurs
affluents à côté de l'ancien testament
l'église atteste l'existence de sources
païenne annonciatrice de marie et du
sauveur des nations
guilbert de nogent est un historien et
théologien d'origine picarde
ab à nogent sous coucy près de soissons
il a écrit son la première croisade il
est l'auteur de la fameuse phrase des
ieg et stappert franckos les exploits de
dieu par les francs
dans son autobiographie écrite vers ans
114 il relate entre autres l'histoire de
son abbaye
lors de fouilles autour de son monastère
guibert constate la présence de vieilles
sépultures dont le mode d'inhumation
l'intriguent
[Musique]
leur hit me baby pas aux standards
chrétiens
à l'évidence il s'agit de tombes païenne
dans la bibliothèque de l'abbaye
l'abbé archéologues découvrent aussi de
très anciens manuscrits qui semblent
fournir la clé de cette énigme
[Musique]
on trouva de plus dans la même église
les écrits composés en verre auquel pour
ma part je n'eusse accordé nulle
autorité ne fusse certains faits qui en
renforce la fiabilité est que de nos
jours encore j'ai pu constater de mes
yeux voici donc l'histoire selon ce
qu'en dit ce manuscrit
au temps du christ régner sur l'île de
bretagne un roi sage et pieux ce roi ne
croyait pas que le comportement des
dieux pu ressembler à celui des hommes
il doit bien exister quelque part au
dessus de ses idoles agité un dieu bon
et véritables qui est le vrai dieu mais
où le chercher un jour le roi entend une
voix du ciel qui lui intime l'ordre de
se rendre en palestine pour connaître
quel est ce dieu
dieu qui montre le meilleur aux bonnes
volontés d'une voix de céleste prayssas
cet homme d'aller jusqu'à jérusalem là
il entendra ce qu'il convient de savoir
sur dieu
après avoir renoncé à son royaume notre
homme entame son voyage traverse la
manche et arrive à nogent sous coucy
pour y faire étape
c'est l'occasion pour gilbert de
raconter un fait d'une haute importance
pour la suite que dit le fameux
manuscrit
un aux gens sous coucy jadis se dressait
un sanctuaire payen il avait été bâti en
l'honneur d'une femme à venir une femme
mystérieuse qui donnerait vie à un homme
dieu
les anciens rapporte et l'on ajoute pour
certains quand ce lieu se trouvait un
très vieux temple consacré ni au nom ni
en l'honneur du existants mais de dire
une femme non en corner qui en ferait un
homme dieu il était donc dédié à la
future mère du dieu à naître
[Musique]
après l'escale à nogent sous coucy le
prince elle repart et gagne par terre et
par mer la cité de jérusalem
[Musique]
il arrive juste après la passion du
christ
[Musique]
depuis peu le sauveur avait souffert il
avait ressuscité d'entre les morts était
monté au ciel enfin il avait envoyé
l'esprit le roi breton trouve à la ville
divisée en diverses tensions les uns
refusent en effet les autres les
attestant
le prince celte se porte alors au devant
d'un groupe de gens c'est la sainte
vierge avec les apôtres il apprend de
l'enseignement du christ et ses miracles
surtout il rencontre mari la femme
vierge qui a enfanté dieu
de ses illustres hôtes le chef celte
reçoit menthe reliques qu'il place dans
un coffret ruiz il prend le chemin du
retour vers l'occident
[Musique]
arrivé au sanctuaire payen de nogent
sous coucy il raconte sa merveilleuse
aventure
et tous reconnaissent en sainte marie
mère de jésus la femme qui devaient
enfanter dieu
le prince celte meurt on lan terre à
nogent sous coucy avec son précieux
coffret
des siècles plus tard l'abbaye
chrétienne ayant remplacé l'ancien
temple païen des moines découvriront le
coffret confirmant cette histoire
le christianisme n'a pas effacé le
paganisme des druides il en est au
contraire l'accomplissement attendu
catulle est un poète latin originaire de
vénétie
son chant 64 compte les noces mythique
de pelles et un mortel avec la dst this
pourquoi se rappeler ses noces
[Musique]
parce que de cet hymen va naître un
héros à chine
l'intrépide guerrier qui vaincra la cité
troyenne
les parcs déesse de la fatalité chante à
ce banquet où s'égayent dieu et homme
c'est une rêverie nostalgique sur le
temps béni d'antan une époque
merveilleuse très anciennes ou mortelles
est immortel festoyer ensemble
c'était avant que l'homme ne fut dans
l'ain piété
propice en effet les habitants du ciel
avait coutume de visiter les châteaux
demeures des héros et de se montrer aux
réunions des mortels quand on ne
méprisez pas encore la piété
et de dresser la liste des crimes des
parjures des fautes dont l'homme par la
suite n'a cessé de se rendre coupable
résonne de ce chant mélancolique
l'intuition du péché originel de la
faute qui causa la perdition de
l'humanité
et le souvenir presque douloureux du
monde d'avant avant les grandes sous les
yeux
devant cette offense aux dieux la sainte
lumière s'en est allé
mais il ya aussi le secret espoir que
les du accorderont quand même une chance
aux hommes et que l'âge d'or reviendra
les romains disposait aussi de chants
sacrés censés prédire le futur et guider
les hommes
aux heures de grand père ils ont tenté
d'en interpréter le sens pour
s'approprier la bienveillance des dieux
[Musique]
virgile et le plus grand poète latin
s'inspirant de la prophétie de la
sibylle 'document il compte la naissance
d'un divine enfants qui sortira
l'humanité de l'âge du fer pour la
rétablir dans un nouvel âge d'or
il vient déjà l'âge ultime chanté par la
sibylle de cumes le grand ordre des
siècles des leçons recommencement déjà
revient et la vierge et les royaumes de
saturne déjà du haut des cieux descend
une nouvelle race toi chastrusse in soit
favorable à l'enfant qui naît par lui ce
sera d'abord la race de fer et surgir à
celle d'or dans le monde entier déjà
règne ton apollon
l'attend messianique de cet enfant divin
témoigne de l'atmosphère anxieuse et
mystique où baigne cette époque juste
avant l'incarnation de dieu
durant l'antiquité tout ce qui touche
aux choses de l'esprit convergent vers
athènes la cité intellectuelle
ici trône des statuts des dieux témoin
silencieux de la profonde piété des
habitants
or un détail surprend on sait par
l'apôtre saint paul que les athéniens
avait érigé parmi toutes ces créatures
mythologiques un hôtel au dieu inconnu
à thénia à tous égards vous êtes je le
vois les plus religieux les hommes
parcourant en effet votre ville et
considérant vos monuments sacrés j'ai
trouvé jusqu'à un hôtel avec inscription
au dieu inconnu et bien ce que vous
adorez sans le connaître je viens moi
vous l'annoncer
avec le temps les athéniens se
convertiront ils finiront par
reconnaître le christ dans leur célèbre
dieu inconnu
que ce soit les celtes avec notre dame
des druides les romains avec la sibylle
de cumes où les grecs avec le dieu
inconnu les païens était déjà inspiré
par le saint-esprit de la venue
prochaine du christ
selon le nouveau testament les premiers
hommes à avoir reconnu la naissance du
divin enfant sont des païens il s'agit
des fameux mages venus d'orient est
guidé par une étoile
jésus étant né à bethléem du julier
voici que des mages venus d'orient
arrivèrent à jérusalem en dix ans où est
le roi des juifs qui vient de naître
nous avons vu en effet son astre sont
levés et sont venus lui rendre hommage
on peut se demander si cette course à
l'étoile n'aurait pas un lien avec la
précession des équinoxes
la naissance du christ coïncident plus
ou moins avec cette époque transitoire
entre les signe du bélier et du poisson
au cours des siècles l'église précisera
que les mages était roi en référence un
psaume de l'ancien testament
les rois de tercis aider ils amèneront
des offrandes les rois de sehba et de
sabha apporteront leur tribu tous les
rois se prosterneront devant lui toutes
les nations le serviront
ce n'est qu'au huitième siècle que
l'occident leur assignera les noms de
melchior balthazar et gaz par
an -27 depuis rome octave auguste
proclame la naissance de l' empire et
jette les bases du culte impérial
ce culte d'un jour nouveau prétend faire
de l'empereur une sorte de divinité
[Musique]
un navire voguer de grèce vers l'italie
tout à coup en provenance du nil retenti
une voie sûre humaine qui appelle un
certain tanus
au troisième appel tanus le pilote du
navire répond à la voie
alors la voix lui ordonne quand tu sera
à la hauteur de palau death annonce que
le grand pan est mort
la rumeur concernant cette mystérieuse
divinité se diffuse alors dans tout
l'empiré
au point que l'empereur tibère convoque
tamuz à rome
le bruit sans répandit bientôt d'un rhum
est amusé demandait à la cour par
guilbert césar le monarque ajoute-t-elle
confiance à son rapport qui leur donna
une enquête et des recherches au sujet
de ce pan les hommes éclairés qu'il
avait un grand nombre autour de lui
conjectures air que c'était un fils de
mercure et de pénélope
enfin aux côtés de tous les paliers en
quête de réponses l'ancien testament
attendaient le messie
dans isaïe et il est dit qu'une vierge
doit enfanter un dieu sauveur
c'est pourquoi le seigneur lui même vous
donnera un signe voici la jeune femme
est enceinte elle va enfanter un fils et
a le nommera dieu avec nous
ainsi sur une étendue immense dont la
méditerranée le coeur la convergence des
âmes façonne déjà le monde nouveau
mais pour que les temps sa complice une
mort est une résurrection se prépare
à travers son fils jésus christ dieu
envoie tous les hommes de la terre un
message d'amour et la promesse de la vie
éternelle dans l'au delà
[Musique]
or ce message pourtant magnifique est
insupportable aux oreilles d'un certain
peuples d'orient et quelque chose va
bientôt séparer ce peuple du reste des
hommes
les juifs espéraient eux aussi la venue
du sauveur
[Musique]
mais ils le voyaient comme un dieu
arbitraire exclusif qui à eux seuls
d'andré pouvoir sur le monde entier
leur immense désillusion se met aussitôt
en
n1 force d'acharnement le sens des
drains fini par obtenir du pouvoir
romain l'exécution publique du christ
en retour de ce crime fariza heat contre
dieu une malédiction infinie s'abat sur
les juifs
après la résurrection du christ puis le
paraclet envoyé aux apôtres les peuples
païens apprennent l'évangile
loin de renier leur propre religion
c'est au contraire en y faisant
référence que certains paille
injustifiée alors leur propre conversion
pour ses premiers chrétiens jésus n'est
pas un dieu étranger il est celui qui
avait annoncé de longue date les
prophéties celui qu'attendaient les
gaulois et bien d'autres peuples dans le
monde
comme l'affirment saint-pierre dans les
actes des apôtres
les patients ont reçu dans leur âme eux
aussi l'inspiration divine du
saint-esprit
dieu qui connaît les coeurs avait
témoigné en faveur des gentils en leur
donnant l'esprit-saint tout comme à nous
les druides avait donc raison mais de la
vierge qui devaient enfanter le fils
héroïques de dieu a vécu parmi les
mortels pour annoncer la nouvelle loi du
monde
de nombreux auteurs anciens parlent des
druides en général et de leur clergé en
particulier mais un seul bruit nous est
connue en personne grâce à trois textes
indépendant ce droid se nomme dillies
ciac il est et demain
la tribu des indiens est situé sur un
centre stratégique de la gaule avec
trois axes fluviaux la loire la seine et
le court saône rhône ce qui fait de leur
région un carrefour majeur de l'occident
depuis un pacte signé en moins 124 et de
1,0 main se considère comme un peuple
frère et consanguins
seul le peuple troyen pourtant plus ou
moins mythique a eu droit au même
privilège
peut-être et de 1,0 minces estime et ils
les seuls descendants des troyens
d'autrefois
cicéron et l'écrivain latin de référence
tant par la qualité de ses écrits que
par leur abondance il fut aussi un homme
politique et avocat
or vers moins 60 cicéron reçoit 10
lisjak chez lui et chose rare de la part
d'un intellectuel romain envers un
étranger il en parle en termes élogieux
il donne de dili ciac sa profession de
druide ses compétences de philosophes et
ses vertus de futurologue
ce procès était de divination n'a pas
été non plus négliger chez les barbares
puisqu'en gaulle il y a les druides
parmi eux j'ai connu les humains davis
yak tournon admirateurs qui déclarait
posséder la science de la nature que les
grecs appellent philosophie et qui
prédisait l'avenir en partie par les
augures en parquet par la conjecture
druide mais aussi hommes politiques et
diplomates dit vicié qui se trouve en
italie pour négocier un accord avec la
république romaine
à la même époque en effet s'évitant
gaulle une guerre civile où s'opposent
deux partis de coalition dominé par deux
tribus les et demain et les arvernes
une guerre civile suicidaire à laquelle
s'invitent de plus en plus des tribus
germaniques en quête de terres et de
pillages
[Musique]
c'est donc au nom d'une partie des
tribus gauloises que divise yak propose
un partenariat de défense commune aux
romains
les romains écoutent avec attention
l'exposé du druide ambassadeur car
quelques décennies plus tôt saint breton
avait semé la terreur jusqu'au sud des
alpes et menacer directement l'italie
ce rapprochement militaire gallo-romain
contre les germains est au coeur de
l'accord diplomatique
c'est de là que découle l'action menée
ensuite par césar qui gouvernent alors
l'italie du nord comme il le dit lui
même en évoquant les et demain et leurs
alliés
c'est pour répondre en grande partie à
leurs prières que césar vient
d'entreprendre la guerre
césar connais fort bien indivis ciac les
deux hommes s'estiment beaucoup et l'on
sent chez césar l'aveu d'une admiration
mutuelle
césar connaissait l'extrême dévouement
de litiges issia qu'au peuple romain
l'extrême attachement à sa personne la
fidélité absolue la justice la maîtrise
de soi
sur le théâtre des opérations
il y as complémentarité tactique entre
les contingents de cavaliers gaulois et
les légions de fantassins romain à
maintes reprises c'est difficile quand
personne qui conduit la coalition à
travers les routes de gaulle comme par
exemple durant la campagne contre le roi
germanique are you viste
pour résumer la guerre des gaules voici
ce qu'ont dit souhaité sommes cent
cinquante ans plus tard dans sa
biographie de jules césar
voici à peu près ce qu'on rapporte de
ses 9 ans de gouvernement toute la gaule
comprise entre les pyrénées les adh les
cévennes le rhin et le rhône soit à
périmètre de 3 millions 200 mille pas à
l'exception des sites et alliés et
méritante ils la réduisent et en
province romaine et les tabliers l'impôt
annuel à 40 millions de sesterces
à l'exception des sites et alliés et
méritante
[Musique]
onu souhaitait connaître les effectifs
militaires de ses alliés gaulois or ni
césar ni ses successeurs n'en donne les
chiffres
il y a peut être anguille sous roche
il s'agit là en effet de la version
romaine des événements
qu'en at il été en réalité
pour y répondre il faudrait disposer de
la version gauloise
or cette version existe
les panégyriques de l'antiquité latine
sont un corpus de discours composé par
des professeurs d'éloquence gaulois
entre 289 et 389 est adressé aux
empereurs
serre et heures gaulois semble plus ou
moins occupé la fonction des anciens
barde
le panégyrique de 312 consacré à
constantin a été écrit par un et deux
fidèles à la mémoire orale de sa tribu
l'auteur évoque pour commencer les liens
antique et d'égalité de rang entre et de
1,0 main la guerre civile entre gaulois
et les intrusions des germains
se remémorant divisia que sans le nommer
il dresse le tableau vivant et
pittoresque du chef gaulois parlant au
sénat romain
seuls les et du un nid effrayés de
crainte ni poussé par la flatterie mais
franc d'une noble charité se sont
estimés frère du peuple romain et on
méritait d'être ainsi appelé
c'est en effet par ce nom à l'exception
du tout autre terme de parenté que se
montre et l'affection commune et
l'égalité de rang quand par la suite
jalouse la nouvelle gloire de cette
fraternité avec les romains les nations
voisines eurent appelé à laurède
légèrement le chef d edu un vote au
sénat et il explose à la faire invité à
s'asseoir sans avoir rien réclamer pour
lui il préféra plaider sa cause appuyé
sur son bouclier
dans cette version gauloise indépendante
de celle de césar et de ce fait tonne on
retrouve les ingrédients centraux de la
faire sauf que notre barde va inverser
le rôle principal
ce sont les actes d et demain et de
leurs alliés qui vont ici être mis en
relief
les gaulois du parti et demain
mobilisent leur puissante cavalerie les
romains en ayant presque pas ils
mobilisent leurs fantassins
ils fournissent nourriture et armes
à travers toute la gaule divisia
qu'emmène césar et césar apparaît moins
ici comme un conquérant que comme un
auxiliaire
ce sont donc les hesdin et leurs alliés
qui prennent la responsabilité
historique d'unir la celtique et la
belgique en les faisant passer dans l'
empire qui doit naître
ayant obtenu gain de cause d'initiales
fut le premier à conduire l'armée
romaine et césar au delà du rhône
jusqu'à cette époque on appelait route
de la gaule la gaule transalpine mais
tout ce qui est contenu entre le rhin
l'océan les pyrénées et les alpes ce
sont les et dumas qui l'ont fait passer
dans l'empiré romain après avoir offert
des quartiers d'hiver fourni des vivres
en abondance fabriquer des armes et
porter secours en infanterie en cavale
si bien qu'on unissant dans une même
pétou l'époque de la celtic et de la
belgique il aura vu aux barbares tous
ceux qui l'ont rejointe aux romains
la version gauloise contredit la version
romaine sur un point capital
jamais la gaule n'a été vaincu ni envahi
par les romains
c'est le parti est de 1 qui a préparé la
gaule au futur empire
un son retour en italie césar traîne
enchaîner derrière lui vercingétorix le
chef d'une des deux factions politiques
de la gaule
[Musique]
mais césar présente abusivement le
malheureux vercingétorix comme le chef
de la gaule entière qui l'aurait réduite
à sa merci
aux yeux du sénat et du peuple romain
césar peut ainsi passer pour un
conquérant ce qui propulse eu sa
carrière politique il ya là beaucoup de
propagande et une insidieuse déformation
de la réalité historique
[Musique]
les commentaires de césar appelé la
guerre des gaules raconte avec quelques
vérités le voyage itinérant de césar en
gaule en germanie et en bretagne
mais les proportions des forces en
présence ils sont totalement fausses et
voire inverser
la réalité était sans doute bien
différente
d'une part dans cette guerre civile en
gaule césar et ses légions sont une
force d'appoint il ne joue pas le
premier rôle
d'autre part l'armée gauloise que
préside guy vissac possède un poids
politique diplomatique logistique et
militaire beaucoup plus important
au final c'est peut être le rôle de
division ac et de son alliance gauloise
qu'il faudrait revoir à la hausse
bientôt coiffant tribus gauloises et
république romaine va naître un espace
commun de protection mutuelle lampy
[Musique]
projet ambitieux et prometteur dont le
druide initiale fut sans doute en partie
l'initiateur
[Musique]
la gaule a gagné sa guerre civile comme
l'archéologie va emporter maintenant
témoignages
beaucoup de gaulois souhaitait de longue
date un partenariat avec rome pour
ouvrir le pays profond vers l'horizon
c'est un peu la connexion internet de
l'antiquité
[Musique]
des césar et ses légions reparti pour
rome où les attend une guerre civile les
gaulois commencent les travaux d'un
ambitieux réseau routier qui traversera
le pays de la méditerranée au pas de
calais
[Musique]
cette colonne vertébrale de la gaule
attribué à tort au général romain
agrippa est d'origine gauloise
durant le demi siècle avant notre ère
les promesses se concrétisent
dès l'instauration de lempire par
auguste les tribus gauloises font leur
capitale fédérale à la jonction rhône
saône
en hommage au dieu national hugues on
donne à cette capitale politique le nom
de luc deux hommes la colline de l'ugs
devenu lion
au moins douze le culte impérial y est
ouvert
c'est le sanctuaire des trois gaules
dont la fête nationale le 1er août se
calque sur la fête celtique de l'udc
le premier prêtre à tenir l'hôtel ça
crée des trois gaules et vert condat
reid huguenots ce1 et 2
tandis que la gaule s'intègre à l'
empire les et demain transfèrent leur
capital sur l' axe majeur qu'est la voie
agrippa peu à peu bibracte l'ancien
oppidum s'efface au profit de cette
ville nouvelle nommée en l'honneur de
l'empereur auguste augusto d'un homme
qui deviendra autun
[Musique]
l'entousiasme des et demain comme des
gaulois en général est ainsi
l'aboutissement d'une maturité politique
de long terme
l'ouvragé urbain est considérable autun
s'entoure d'une muraille de 6 km de long
[Musique]
son théâtre large de 148 m et le plus
grand de tous lempire avec celui de
pompey à rome
son amphithéâtre est l'un des plus
grands d'occident il s'y trouve une
école de gladiateurs
[Musique]
en outre au teint possède le plus grand
centre universitaire d'occident
ces universités porte le nom d' écoles
méniennes
en langue indo-européenne la racine même
veut dire esprit pensée intelligence
on la retrouve en sanskrit en latin on
vieillir landais en gaulois
portant un nom gaulois les écoles
méniennes ou écoles de l'esprit sont le
cerveau du pays
[Musique]
les professeurs de ces universités sont
des druides d'ailleurs l'emplacement de
ces écoles supérieures précisément au
pays du druide divisia que chez les et
demain ne doit sûrement rien au hasard
[Musique]
on y enseigne les lettres les langues
étrangères latin y le droit la
rhétorique la médecine
surtout les écoles méniennes ont une
particularité une galerie présente des
portiques images et
là sur les murs et sur les chapiteaux
des colonnes sont gravés ou dessiné des
cartes avec les contours du monde connu
terre océan fleuve pays ville
le tout à l'échelle en précisant les
distances
indispensable pour les leçons de
géographie d'histoire ou de sciences
naturelles ses cartes encyclopédique
offre un confort d'enseignement unique à
cette époque
un professeur d'éloquence gaulois eumène
d'autun et veut qu'en
298,7 extraordinaire salle de géographie
il s'agit du témoignage le plus net sur
l'existence de cartes dans l'antiquité
qu en outre la jeunesse se voit sur ces
portiques et contemple chaque jour
toutes les terres et toutes les mers et
tout ce qu'il y a deux villes deux
peuples deux nations que les invincibles
prince restaure par bonté soumettent par
force ou fige paraît froid puisque c'est
là comme que l'as vu toi même qu'il faut
instruire la jeunesse et que l'on
apprend plus clairement par les yeux ce
qu'il est plus difficile de percevoir à
l'oreille on a exposé tous les lieux
avec leur nom leur étendue leurs
distances et tout ce qu'il y a partout
de fleuve avec leurs sources et leurs
estuaires et la hausse incurvé golf
côtier là où l'océan entoure le monde de
sons et rack ou le pénètre de ces flots
autun présente aussi une vie religieuse
très intense
les ateliers de poterie produite en
série des vastes pour la liturgie et des
statuettes en terre blanche que l'on
exporte en gaule et à l'étranger
la ville nouvelle vénère nos dieux
celtique parfois associées à des noms
gréco-romain dans un souci de synthèse
théologique
le sanctuaire de belenos ou apollon
d'une beauté exceptionnelle dispose de
bain bouillonnant pour les cures
thermales
[Musique]
des fouilles ont révélé une dédicace à
la déesse bibracte qui porte le nom de
l'ancienne capitale et de haine
peut-être équivalente à athéna déesse
d'athènes et à la romaine minerve
les fouilles ont aussi ressuscité le
dieu avalos son nom gaulois provient de
hand très près fixes intensifs et de
valo ce prince souverain
il s'agit d'une épique l'aise un surnom
pour désigner le grand souverain des
dieux gaulois
et la dédicace est signée d'un curieux
personnage
odieux avalos de la part de norman et
used as lu ce en qualité de but tu à
terre
qu'ils aient le goût tu à terre
en gaulois à terre veut dire père aiguë
tu vois à l'instar des langues
germaniques but tu pourrais aussi avoir
le sens de dieu comme dans l'allemand
got et l'anglais god
le but eut à terre et le père
invocateurs où le père divin
c'est peut-être ce terme subtil que les
grecs ont traduit par sem noté dieu
vénérable donné par diogène laërce comme
équivalent à druide on la cité au début
du documentaire
d'une certaine façon le but la terre est
l'ancêtre de la baie médiévale
ainsi norman élus saluent ce en sa
qualité de but la terre occupe la
fonction d' abbey et de recteur de
l'université d'autun
ce but la terre d'autun fait écho au but
la terre qui officiait jadis au pays des
carnutes du temps de division ac et
vercingétorix et dont pas le commentaire
de la guerre des gaules
tout se passe comme si le centre
universitaire des écoles méniennes était
l'héritier de l'ancienne assemblée des
druides
[Musique]
d'où la présence ici et là du nucléaire
capitale universitaire médical
religieuses culturelles voire
touristique hôtes un accueil étudiants
pèlerins malades venus parfois de loin
elle forme les futures élites civiles
hauts fonctionnaires magistrats avocats
médecins historien géographe professeur
gauloise ou étrangers
au tournant de notre ère autant
s'affirme comme la vitrine
intellectuelle de cette nouvelle gaulle
connecter à l' empire
en
lan 21 de notre ère des chefs gaulois se
rebelle contre la bureaucratie centrale
les principaux meneurs sont les devins
sacro vire et le trévires florus
tous deux possèdent la citoyenneté
romaine
ce sont des notables
les raisons du soulèvement sont surtout
fiscales
la même année à cause du poids de la
dette des chefferies gauloise
entreprirent d'une rébellion dont les
plus vils instigateurs était parmi les
traits virgile florus et chez les élus
un jules sacro vire tous deux nobles et
issus des yeux ayant reçu la citoyenneté
romaine pour leurs bienfaits
l'état romain n'est pas l' empire ce que
sacre vire et fleurus rejette c'est la
décadence et le parasitisme de
l'empereur tibère et non la connexion à
l' empire
il y aurait d'ailleurs un non-sens à
penser que la gaule grand bénéficiaire
du réseau impérial aurait velléités à
sont isolés
la liberté que l'on revendique c'est
l'autonomie fiscale
le contraste entre la gaule florissante
et l'italie qui femme est patent les
auteurs de l'époque l'avait constaté
c'est ce qui pousse tacite à faire dire
aux révoltés gaulois
le temps est venu de recouvrer la
liberté si au vu de l'état florissant
des gaulois on songe à l'épuisement de
l'italie à la mollesse de la plèbe
romaine et ses armées qui ont de forts
que ce qui est étranger
dans les armées impériales en effet
nombreux sont les gaulois c'est ainsi
qu'en belgique s'affrontent deux
généraux celte au pays des trévires le
révolté florus et vaincu par le
loyalistes induces de son côté sacro
vire se rend d'abord chez les ans des
caves et les turone où éclatent des
émeutes qui sont rapidement mater puis
il rejoint hautain et sa ville
universitaire sacro vire soulève la
population et de m et entraîne dans son
sillon révolutionnaire des masses
d'étudiants
avec des troupes armées sacre aux verts
s'étaient emparés d'autun la capitale
régionale afin de s'adjoindre les jeunes
de la noblesse gauloise qui se
consacrent tisséo aux études et par ce
gage leurs parents et leurs proches
sacro vie réunis derrière lui dix mille
légionnaires auxquels s'ajoutent des
milices de civils et de chasseurs ainsi
que des élèves gladiateurs
reconnaissables à leur corps cuirassé en
tout quarante mille 1
à rome enfle la rumeur de ce soulèvement
lointain et si toute la gaule
s'embrasait puis l'espagne puis la
germanie
l'empereur tibère demeure inerte
en gaule des légions loyalistes pascal
attaque elle commence par dévasté le
pays des ces clubs alliés des et 2 1
puis elle marche sur autun où les attend
de pied ferme l'armée de s'accroupir
à 12000 dota sur une plaine apparurent
sacro verrait ses troupes à l'avant
garde il avait placé ces gladiateurs
cuirassé sur les côtés ces cohortes à
l'arrière les moins armés lui même parmi
les chefs aller sur son cheval superbe
rappelant les anciennes gloires des
gaulois et quel revers il avait porté
aux romains
mais le rapport de forces est
asymétrique entre cette coalition
hétéroclite plus furieuse qu'efficace et
des légions sur entraînés au combat
tactique
[Musique]
vaincus sacro vire se replie dans autun
puis gagne avec ces derniers sommes un
village tout proche
là les héros oubliés livrent leur vie
aux flammes divine et tous se donnent la
mort au milieu du bûcher à redon
cette révolte qui aura soulevé et demain
trévires sequans turone dans des caves
et certaines légion en place s'est
résolu localement sans intervention de
rome
selon l'historien romain pathé recul us
sacre vire aurait été un chef national
puisqu'il porte le titre de primat des
gaules
cette guerre ô combien pénible suscité
par sac revenir le primat des gaules et
jules florus tivers la réprima avec
quelle rapidité et courage c'est bien
que le peuple rom a appris sa victoire
avant d'avoir appris qu'ils combattaient
le messager de la victoire ayant précédé
les nouvelles du danger
la formule belle et alambiqué prouve
surtout que tiber n'est pour rien dans
l'issue de cette guerre fiscale des
gaules
qui est vraiment sacro vire
[Musique]
son nom donne peut-être l'explication
en gaulois sacre on veut dire sacré et
viros hommes le sacre vire c'est l'homme
sacré où le saint homme
il s'agit donc d'un titre religieux
accordée au souverain druide
probablement le but la terre
[Musique]
ainsi cette révolte de synchro vire est
une riposte gauloise au harcèlement
fiscal mais aussi religieux de la
bureaucratie romaine
[Musique]
car jusque là les druides bénéficier
d'une exemption fiscale hérité de la
nuit des temps et que rome avait dûment
respectée lors de l'instauration de l'
empire
selon la coutume les druides eux ne vont
pas à la guerre et ne paient aucun impôt
ils sont exemptés de service militaire
et de toute corvée
cette exemption fiscale et militaire
avait fait partie des négociations
pratique entre le druide divisia qu est
le sénat romain
ce qui a fait déborder le chaudron
gaulois c'est le parjure romain et
l'abrogation de ce privilège clérical
car c'est précisément à cette époque que
tiber prend des mesures contre les
druides
c'est le gouvernement de l'empereur
tibère qui a supprimé leur druide et
cette race de 2 20 et 2 médecins
d'où la colère antifiscale
l'échauffement religieux et la volonté
de conserver son autonomie dans l'
empire quant aux druides quoique
persécutés dans les lois ils
continueront à officier sans être
vraiment inquiété
[Musique]
ce que les empereurs romains reproche
surtout à certains druide c'est le refus
d'honorer le culte impérial
et de comploter contre l'autorité de
rome
[Musique]
c'est pourquoi poursuit vont d'abord la
politique de tibère claude surenchéri en
faisant interdire la religion druidique
chez les gaulois closes abolies
complètement à la cruelle et sauvage
religion les druides qui s'offusquent
avaient été interdites seulement aux
citoyens
cette interdiction grandiloquente sera
toutefois plus formelle que réelle
elle vise plus à satisfaire le sénat
qu'à comprendre la gaule il y as loin de
la coupe aux lèvres
en lan 48 c'est à dire pour le
centenaire de la fin de la guerre des
gaules l'empereur claude prononce cette
fois un discours en faveur de l'accord
de la citoyenneté romaine aux gaulois
pour honorer ce tournant des notables et
2 1 sont invités au sénat de rome
suite au discours du prince en rendit à
joris consulte les et du vin optèrent
les premiers le droit de siéger au sénat
de rome cela leur fait accorder du fait
de l'ancienne alliance et parce que seul
parmi les gaulois ils font usage du nom
de frère du peuple romain
ainsi une génération après la
persécution fiscal de tibère claude
corrige le tir et apaise les consciences
si les eduens sont les grands vainqueurs
de cette connexion impérial on aurait
tort de croire qu'ils sont les seuls
leurs vieux rivaux les arts verts ne
sont pas en reste
chez les celtes le dieu principal se
nomme l'udc son nom signifie lumière
luc est un dieu solaire dont le culte
est souvent rendue sur les collines et
les auteurs
[Musique]
verlan 50 de notre ère les arvernes font
appel à un sculpteur grec zeno d'or pour
édifier sur l'un de leurs puits
volcanique une immense statue en bronze
à l'éffigie de l'ugs nommé mercure en
latin
[Musique]
c'est alors la plus grande statue en
bronze de l'époque
la dimension de toutes les statues de ce
genre a été surpassé de notre temps par
le mercure que anneaux d'or a fait
passer des gaulois des arvernes au prix
de 400 mille sesterces e pour la
manoeuvre pendant dix ans
ainsi en ce 1er siècle la gaule
florissante ce peuple de géants de
bronze et les gaulois rentrer au sénat
rome
[Musique]
la gaule c'est l'homme fort de lempire
rome l'homme malade
ayant ouï dire que les arvernes avait
fait ériger sur leurs terres une statue
colossale de l'ordre national l'empereur
néron en prend ombrage
il convoque alors à rome le fameux et
inodore et convient avec le sculpteur
grec d'une commande n'iront veut une
statue colossale de lui même
[Musique]
ayant suffisamment fait connaître son
talent zeno d'or fut demandée par néron
à rome où il exécuta le colosse destiné
à représenter ce prince cette statue
haute de 110 pieds est aujourd'hui un
objet de culte ayant été consacrée au
soleil après la condamnation des crimes
de néron
ainsi tandis que les gaulois édifie des
statuts de leur propre dieu grâce à
leurs bénéfices néron grèvent le budget
de rome pour satisfaire sa mégalomanie
narcissique
[Musique]
les moeurs de néron sont d'une
fascinante dépravation
en tant qu'homme il épouse d'abord
sporuce un eunuque efféminé
puis voulons expérimenter l'envers des
choses il se déguise lui-même en jeune
femme épouse pythagore as un esclave
affranchi
la cour latine participent à ces festins
grandiose peu lui chaut la ruine pourvu
qu'elle s'amuse le prince et prodiguent
les fastes de la débauche seront
financés par le fisc tel est le
privilège de rome
en 64 remet ravagé par un incendie
le plus grand de son histoire
[Musique]
des indices plaident en faveur d'un
attentat
et la rumeur publique accuse néron d'en
être le commanditaire
on prétend même que néron la lire en
mains sales maudier la chute 10 lyon
devant la ville en flammes
car la rumeur avait couru qu'au moment
où la ville étaient en flammes
néron était monté sur son théâtre privé
et avait chanté la ruine de 3 assimilant
les malheurs présent aux anciens
désastre
pour calmer le destin on invoque les
divinités mais cela n'apaise pas le
peuple qui accuse néron lui même
[Musique]
en retour néron désigne d'autres
coupables les chrétiens
mais aucuns moyens humains ni largesses
du prince ni prière au dieu ne faisait
taire la famille c'est sur ordre croyait
tous qu'il y avait eu un centime pour
écarter ces rumeurs néron à +1 et livra
au châtiment est les plus recherchés des
gens à y pour leurs turpitudes que la
foule nommé chrétiens selon leur vient
du christ qui sous tibère avaient été
livrés au supplice par le procurateur
ponce pilate
au cirque des chrétiens sont jetés en
pâture aux fauves
[Musique]
la nuit d'autres sont suspendus
recouvert de combustible est transformé
en torche vivante pour l'éclairage des
rues
même les païens les moins suspect de
connivence avec les chrétiens en sont
révoltés
non enfin vient l'heure de solder les
comptes la ruine un coup rome presque
anéanti le fisc des hausses les temples
encore debout et s'en va pressurer les
provinces
par ailleurs nul n'ignore dans l' empire
que néron a commandité le meurtre de sa
propre mère agrippine
au nord des alpes on est horrifiée du
spectacle crépusculaire qu'offre la
versatile italie dans l' empire la gaule
est un exemple rome un gouffre
l'empereur info
alors que va faire la gaule la gaule a
trop peu vrai dans l' empire pour le
quitter elle l empire c'est pourquoi on
68 c'est un chef gaulois du nom de
vindex qui prend l'initiative du
soulèvement
vindex est un noble d'aquitaine qui
siège au sénat romain en sa qualité de
général il convoque l'assemblée à lyon
que veuves index il refuse
l'effondrement du régime il veut chasser
néron du pouvoir
[Musique]
et son argument et patriotique c'est aux
gaulois l'homme fort de l'enppi de
libérer le genre humain
d'après la recherche numismatique voici
sans doute le véritable visage de ce
général
on le trouve sur une monnaie portant le
titre mars ultor c'est-à-dire mars
vengeurs
le chef de guerre vindex a en effet
venger l'honneur de l' empire contre
l'indigné rend le jeu de mot vient du
nom même de vindex qui signifie aussi
vengeurs en latin
mais vint d'exporter t'il vraiment selon
prédestiné
il existe en gaule un thème de noms
propres très proche phonétiquement de
vindex est très fréquent vin d'os
20 doses veut dire blanc heureux en
gaulois
peut être était ce le nom d'origine de
20 des kz
le discours de ce général devant
l'assemblée des gaules on le connaît
grâce à l'historien dion cassius
néron à piller tout l'univers romain il
a fait périr toute la fleur du sénat il
a déshonoré tué sa mère et ne conserve
pas même l'apparence de l'empereur je
les ai vus a misé alliés croyez-moi je
l' ai vu cet homme c'est un homme que le
mari de sporuce que l'épousé pythagore
as dans l'enceinte du théâtre et on
donnerait un pareil être les noms de
césar d'empereur d'auguste non non que
nulle outrage ces noms sacrés levé vous
donc enfin secours et vous vous même
secours et les romains et délivrer
l'univers entier
mais qui pour remplacer l'infâme néron
on cherche une roue de secours on trouve
galba
gal ba est un romain de haute noblesse
d'âge mûr gouverneur en hispanie
la rébellion gauloise est à l'oeuvre
n'iront aux abois
après avoir supporté intel prince un peu
moins de 14 ans le monde le déposa enfin
l'initiative revint aux gaulois et à
leurs chefs julve index qui tenait alors
cette province en tant que général à
naples le jour anniversaire où il avait
tué sa mère néron a pris le soulèvement
des gaules
cet appel à renverser néron est
l'étincelle qui déclenché la guerre
civile
bientôt le sénat haute le titre
d'empereur admirons qui se suicide
commence alors l'année dit des quatre
empereurs galbe à hotton et vitellius
traverse l'histoire sans avoir vraiment
régner
c'est vespasien qui va s'efforcer de
rétablir l'autorité
en gaule la révolte gronde encore et des
tribus s'affrontent en 69 le chef des
lingons jules sabin se fait proclamer
césar des gaules par ses soutiens
mais le coup de force échouent les
lagons sont vaincus par l'essai quan
rester fidèle à vespasien
sa main s'échappe
plutôt que de partir en errance sabam
ont alors un stratagème avec son épouse
eponine
bientôt la villa familiale prend feu est
partout la rumeur se répand que sabah
s'est suicidé
pour répandre le bruit de son décès
jules ça m'a incendiée à la maison où il
s'était réfugié ont cru qu'il s'y était
volontairement donné la mort
devant tout le monde la dévouée eponine
porte le deuil le nom d'epo nine et tout
empreint de religiosité druidique
allusion à epône à la déesse jument de
la gaule
[Musique]
en réalité sous le simulacre de suicide
sabah s'est caché dans une grotte ou
dans un tombeau
et c'est son épouse qui lui assure
l'intendance
pendant neuf ans l'habile eponine mène
la double vie de veuves éplorées en
société et des pousses clandestine en
secret apportant à sa moitié le boire et
le manger
[Musique]
mais aussi de ses amours dérobé avec son
mari en cavale éponyme va enfanter deux
fils
hélas vient le jour où l'on découvre le
pot-aux-roses
[Musique]
mise aux arrêts toute la famille est
aussitôt transféré à rome devant
vespasien
[Musique]
cherchant d'abord la clémence la jeune
mère de famille montre au chef de l'état
ses deux enfants encore en bas âge et
lui dit
ses fils césar je les ai enfanté dans la
tombe puis nourrit afin que nous soyons
plus nombreux à te supplier
le pathétique de la scène arrache
quelques larmes avec bazian qui lui
proposons retour la vie sauve à ses fils
et à elle-même mais pas à sa main son
mari coupable de rébellion
refus d'eponine qui rejette toute
séparation d'avec l'homme de sa vie et
de lancer au visage de vespasien ces
mots fulgurant je renonce à la grâce je
demande accompagnée aux époux car dans
les ténèbres sous la terre j'ai vécu
plus heureuse que toi sur ton trône
le couple gaulois unis dans les joies
intime et dans les épreuves du sort le
devient aussi dans la main
pour l'éternité
[Musique]
quant à vespasien il décède peu après
son règne de 69 à 79 n'aura en fait duré
que le temps des amours tombale
d'eponine et de son mari
toutes ces révolutions derrière sacre
vire vindex ou sabin font sens
si l'on pire se déchire c'est parce que
rome est immature et que la gaule tente
violemment d'y remédier
rome détruite par les flammes le
spectacle de ces majestueux décombres
ouvre la voie aux élans mystiques
les druides voit dans la tragédie
romaine le signe divin que le pôle
directeur du monde va franchir les alpes
et que c'est à la gaule désormais de
prendre les destinées de l'univers en 1
mais rien n'avait autant exalter les
gaulois que l' incendie du capitole au
point de croire que c'était la fin de l'
empire jadis rome avait été prise par
les gaulois mais le trône de jupiter et
l' empire était restée intacte
maintenant cet incendie fatal on le
donnait pour un signe de colère céleste
et dans leurs veines religion les drus
de prophétiser que la souveraineté du
monde allait passer aux nations
transalpine
les prêtres gaulois n'exhorte pains
l'isolément ni à un confinement hors de
la méditerranée si les druides prédisent
que l' empire du monde va passer aux
gaulois loin de quitter l empire
il s'agit au contraire d'y rester et de
s'y affirmer aux lois de rome contre les
druides répondent les prophéties des
druides contre rome c'est une rivalité
dans l' empire et pour l' empire
en puissance la gaule dépasse maintenant
l'italie et les druides prophétise que
telle est la volonté des dieux
certains druide rêve même d'accélérer
les événements
[Musique]
sur le territoire et demain en effet un
chef mystique exalte sa patrie il
s'appelle marie qu on le dit en contact
avec le divin et il aspire à hisser la
gaule au dessus du matérialisme décadent
de rome
loin d'être un fou solitaire maric fait
masse et parvient à réunir 8000
combattants
mais son message teinté de surnaturel ne
passe pas auprès de tout le monde à
autun des esprits plus terre à terre se
mobilisent des milices civiles composées
d'étudiants et des garnisons militaires
attaquent et défont les rebelles
curieusement laura charismatique du
personnage ne s'arrête pas là
fait prisonnier maric et livré aux bêtes
féroces
mais contre toute attente les bêtes ne
l'attaquent pas
craignons que la foule ne se laissent
impressionner par les sortilèges de ce
droid vitellius ordonne alors son
exécution
il y as honte à le dire mais au milieu
des grands hommes en danger un certain
maric du peuple des boys à auzat se
mêlèrent la fortune et provoquer les
armes romaine au nom de la volonté
divine
déjà ce libérateur des gaules est ce
dieu car on lui avait donné ce nom ayant
rassemblé huit mille hommes entraînés
les cantons et d'humains voisin quand la
trading cité avec une jeunesse résolu et
les corps a ajouté parvis telus dispersa
la foule exaltée dans la mêlée on
capture amharique et bientôt le jetant
en pâture aux fauves la masse stupide le
crua vulnérables jusqu'à ce que vit
telus le fit tué sous ses yeux
ce nom de dieudonné amharique indique
peut-être qu'il s'agissait du mutua
terre le père qui communique avec les
dieux
jadis aux 4e et 3e siècle avant notre
ère les celtes avait connu une forte
croissance démographique
en quête de nouveaux territoires des
tribus avaient envahi l'italie est
ravagée rome en moins 390
d'autres poussant vers l'est avait
descendu le danube et gagner la grèce
ces campagnes militaires des celtes en
orient hellénique porte le nom de
grandes expéditions en moins 279 ils
pillent le temple de delphes
beaucoup de gaulois parce qu'ensuite en
asie là il s'installe au coeur de
l'anatolie et donnent leur nom et nick à
la ganassi
l'assemblée nationale des galates porte
le nom de drulhe moutons qui signifie le
sanctuaire du chêne
c'est là qu'ils rendent la justice et
décide des grandes orientations
politiques
ledru ne tondez galates est l'équivalent
de notre assemblée des carnutes uno
druide avait coutume de se réunir en
gaule
[Musique]
pendant des siècles les galates
conservent leur langue c'est grâce à eux
qu'aujourd'hui nous sont connues
certains mots gaulois
en 387 saint-jérôme le traducteur de la
bible rapportera la proximité de la
langue des galates avec celle des
gaulois de belgique
les galates à l'exclusion de la langue
grecques parler dans tout l'orient se
servait d'un idiome qui avait avec celui
des habitants de trêve une analogie
frappante est presque complète
ainsi durant l'antiquité tandis qu'en
gaulle on enseigne le grec au centre
universitaire d'autun en anatolie les
galates par le gaulois en terre grecque
l'engouement de certains gaulois tel le
druide divisia qu à bâtir un empire
méditerranéen tenait peut-être aussi à
cette correspondance ou lointaines
pour se faire une idée de cette
fraternité de sang et de langage que
l'on songe à l'intérêt que revêt de nos
jours la france d'amérique
la gala si c'est un peu le québec de
l'antiquité
ces liens étroits entre golega la ci
fournissent aussi un indice sur les
anciennes routes de la christianisation
dès l'aube de notre ère les galates sont
en effet parmi les premiers peuples
païens à rejoindre le christ l'apôtre
paul écrite une épître aux galates
d'élan 50
par la suite des grecs viendront
s'établir en gaule et ils répandront
l'évangile
or ces grecs chrétien aurait beaucoup
gagné à être déjà familier de la langue
du pays
cela semble d'ailleurs être le cas de
saint-irénée deuxième évêque de lyon qui
confessera utilisé surtout la langue
gauloise tu ne trouveras en nous qui
vivent chez les celtes et qui employons
en général la langue locale ni l'art des
discours que nous n'avons pas appris ni
la force de l'écrivain que nous ne
visons pas ni l'élégance des mollets la
persuasion que nous ignorons
saint-irénée ou plus tard saint denis
premier évêque de paris n'aurait-il pas
été dga lattes
versant 70 dans la région de gala si
surgit une mouvance qui aura un impact
jusqu'en gaulle son fondateur se nomme
montant
les montagnes east forme un courant
chrétien original mystique et
millénariste où l'on proclame
l'imminence de la fin des temps il se
réfère essentiellement à l'évangile de
saint jean et à l'apocalypse
notamment un passage quand le christ
annonce qu'après son départ auprès du
père viendra sur terre un nouvel
intercesseur ou paraclet pour guider les
hommes
si vous m'aimez vous garderez mes
commandements et je prierai le père et
vous donnera un autre parent à clé pour
qu'il soit avec vous à jamais l'esprit
de vérité que le monde ne peut pas
recevoir parce qu'il ne le voit pas ni
ne le reconnais vous vous le connaissez
parce qu'il demeure auprès de vous et
qu'il est en vous
le paraclet le saint-esprit l'esprit
consolateur la personne divine qui vole
au secours des persécutés
dans les années 70 des galettes
chrétiens de la mouvance monte à nice tu
débarques temps gaulle
ce sont eux que l'on va retrouver au
célèbre procès de lyon en 177
lempire est alors gouvernée par marc
aurèle en gaule les cérémonies en
l'honneur de l'empereur se déroule
chaque 1er août dans la capitale lyon
or tout comme les druides les chrétiens
refusent souvent de se joindre au culte
impérial et les montagnes east plus que
tout autre puisqu'il ne reconnaissent
d'autorité que celle du saint-esprit
pour rome ce refus d'obéir est un casus
belli
l'empereur fait donc le choix d'en faire
des martyrs ils sont une quarantaine
parmi eux le premier évêque de lyon
presque centenaire saint pothin semaine
et à l'époque où saint-jean écrivait son
évangile et l'apocalypse
après avoir subi de mauvais traitements
pothin meure en prison
les autres martyrs sont livrés aux
arènes du cirque dont une jeune femme du
nom de blandine
[Musique]
tout ce que l'on sait de ses premiers
martyrs chrétiens de gaulle se retrouve
chez l'auteur eusèbe de césarée qui
reproduit dans son oeuvre une lettre en
provenance des chrétiens de lyon
les disciples de montants d'aci bialé
l'été au dot comment c'est alors à
obtenir en phrygie auprès de beaucoup la
réputation de prophètes les nombreux
autres merveilles du charisme diva qui
s'accomplissait encore à cette époque en
plusieurs églises portait en effet
beaucoup de gens sdat croire que ces
gens là avaient eux aussi le don de
prophétie comme un 10 centimes en
existait à leur sujet derechef les
frères de gaulle souvenir leur avis
personnel prudent et tout à fait
orthodoxe est envoyé à diverses lettres
des martyrs couronné parmi eux et crise
alors qu'ils étaient encore dans les
chaînes aux frères d'asie et de friggit
et même à et le ter alors évêque de rome
il négociait en faveur de la paix de
l'église
il existe des liens évidents entre
frères de gaulle et frère d'asie le
terme frère peut certes désigner les
chrétiens entre eux mais à plus forte
raison des chrétiens apparentés
ethniquement des celtes
c'est probablement par l'intermédiaire
des grecs et des galates que la gaule a
reçu l'évangile
l'empereur sévère alexandre n'est en
scierie de parent romain c'est un jeune
homme lettré prudent et pieux qui se
nourrit surtout de littérature
ce garçon pacifique répugnant revanche
aux affaires militaires
un jour qu'il passe par la goule une
druidesse lui lance cette mise en garde
pendant qu'elle marchait une druidesse
lui cria en gaulois va sans espérer la
victoire et ne croit pas en ses soldats
en effet peu après l'empereur ci vers
alexandre est assassiné sous sa tente
par des soldats
sa mort ouvre le demi siècle dit de
l'anarchie militaire
cinquante années d'effondrement
économique et d'intrusion barbares où l'
empire failli disparaître
[Musique]
238 l année record des six empereur
malgré l'instabilité permanente du
pouvoir rome trouve quand même le temps
de fêter son millénaire en avril 248
avec l'empereur philippe l'arabe
la relative tolérance religieuse ne fait
guère de re les chrétiens attachés à
dieu des hobbies souvent à l' empire
payen les païens attaché à l' empire
exige pourtant cette obéissance
l'empereur dèce va d'ailleurs dans ce
sens il reçoit le titre de restitue
torse akroum c'est-à-dire restaurateurs
du paganisme
en 250 des se proclame un édit contre
les chrétiens
l'empereur valérien poursuit la chasse
le christianisme est maintenant
interdite et les biens ecclésiastiques
sont saisis
ces persécutions très inégale frappe
surtout en orient asie ou egypte peu à
rome
presque pas en gaule signé en bretagne
et la décrépitude de l' empire ne sens
poursuit pas moins
d'aces et le premier empereur à mourir
tués par des barbares et valérien le
premier empereur capturé vivant par des
barbares
gallien fils de valérien abroge ces lois
persécutrice
prenant le contre-pied il instaure même
un édit de tolérance qui vend aux
chrétiens leur liberté de culte
pour autant sur le plan géopolitique
lempire accuse le coup
aux marges les frontières se fissure en
orient face aux perses et surtout en
occident face aux germains
souvent dans une société en perdition
l'homme malade c'est l'oligarchie
hors-sol autistes inefficace et
dévirilisé
un rom l'autorité centrale s'évanouit
l'homme fort c'est alors l'échelon local
face au défi du destin les provinces
devront résister seul est repoussé de
leur propre bras les envahisseurs
étrangers
comme autant de vins d'aix deux siècles
plus tôt la gaule se cherche un chemin
non pas hors de lempire mais hors de la
tutelle incapacitantes de rome
dans les campagnes pressé par le fisc
des hommes virils et déclassé paysans
soldats artisans ou sans le sou
commencent à se regrouper face à
l'autorité publique arbitraire est
défaillante ils s'organisent en milices
paramilitaires
loin du fisc et des légions
ces chefferies locales vivent en
autarcie et fonctionne en réseau
d'entr'aide
d'un mot gaulois qui signifie
combattants les chroniques de l'époque
donne à ces sociétés dissidente le nom
de bâts god
phénomène mal répertoriés mais d'une
grande portée historique
les bagues aux doigts occuperont par
intermittence jusqu'à la fin de l'
empire une partie notable du territoire
gaulois
et ses maquisards ne sont pas les seuls
à s'insurger
sur le reste du territoire gaulois les
légions officiel coupe désormais les
ponts avec rome
lord invasions germaniques sur le rhin
l'empereur romain gallien s'est en effet
avéré incapable de réagir c'est donc le
gouverneur de belgique posthume qui se
chargent de refouler les barbares
fort de sa victoire posthume se fait
alors proclamée par ses troupes empereur
des gaules
cette souveraineté d'occident concentre
pouvoir militaire et financier de 260 à
274 émerge ainsi un empire gaulois qui
comprend d'abord la gaule l'île bretonne
libéré
posthume fixe sa capitale à cologne face
aux germains il bat monnaie et redresse
la devise mais meurt assassiné en 269
victorin lui succède
si la gaule et la bretagne lui restent
fidèles d'autres provinces font
défection
l'ibérie la narbonnaise et surtout au
teint de la capitale intellectuelle de
l'occident prennent le parti de rome
[Musique]
en représailles victorin vient à siéger
au teint avec ses troupes
la ville est ravagée
les universités autunoise si couru
durant leurs hôtes empire ne se
remettront jamais vraiment du sac de 270
[Musique]
après la mort précoce de victorin le
gouverneur d'aquitaine t trick assure la
transition
un accord est finalement conclue avec
l'empereur romain aurélien pour refaire
l'unité impérial
unité qui met fin à l'éphémère empire
gaulois
à la fin du 3ème siècle la diversité des
cultes religieux suscite des troubles
permanents
un moyen d'y remédier serait de fondre
toutes ces divinités en une seule
[Musique]
et si tous les dieux n'étaient que les
divers aboutissants d'un même dur à
l'instar des rayons d'une roue autour
d'un seul et même moyeu
de cette synthèse métaphysique est né le
nouveau culte du soleil soleil qui tend
à devenir le dieu des dieux
l'origine de tout l'être primordial
[Musique]
l'empereur aurélien favorise la religion
solaire
il crée pour cela un clergé de prêtres
auxquels ils octroient de généreux
subsides
il rendit de nombreuses lois fort utile
il établit des sacerdoces il éleva au
soleil un temple soutenue de portiques
il irrigue là aussi les factures
d'entretien et la paix des officiers
dans la foulée aurélien promulguer une
loi qui nous paraît familière le 25
décembre devient fête solennelle
on y célèbre la naissance
du soleil invincible
même les chrétiens adhèrent à ce
syncrétisme religieux après tout leurs
jours sacrés un jour du soleil dimanche
et dans les églises on prie le visage
tourné vers l'est en direction du soleil
levant
au iiième et ivème siècle l'empiré
incline donc vers le dieu unique aux
attributs solaire
cette croyance monothéistes fait des
adeptes aussi bien dans le peuple que
chez les soldats ou chez les philosophes
le nom du dieu reste en revanche sujet à
controverse apollon hélios mithra
jésus-christ
en gaule on l'appelle belenos et son
culte y est encore honoré
ozone est un haut fonctionnaire de la
gaule aquitaine homme de lettres à ses
heures il a rédigé diverses oeuvres
plus ou moins chrétiens ils gardent une
sympathie pour l'ancien paganisme
dans un poème adressées à des amis
druide ozone parle du sanctuaire de
belenos dieu celtique de la lumière
solaire et de la bonne santé équivalent
de l'apollon grec ou romain
tu étais de bayeux issu d'une lignée de
druide si l'on dit vrai c'est du temple
de belenos ce que tu tirais ton origine
sacré douvot non le tient pas taire car
c'est ainsi que les initiés appellent
les ministres d'apollon le nom de ton
frère de ton père lors via de fébus et
celui de ton fils d'edf
le père dont le nom provient de fébus se
nommait faiblissent grand prêtre du
sanctuaire de belenos il était de souche
armoricaine
et je ne tirais point le nom du vieux
fait bis gardien du temple de belenos il
en tira le nul richesse pourtant comme
il plaît à dire issu d'une lignée du
druide du peuple américain c'est à
bordeaux qu'il obtint une chair par le
soin de son fils
bordeaux qui tend à remplacer au teint
comme cité intellectuelle fournit ainsi
des places d'universitaires à des
torrides
le nom de belenos provient de la racine
indo-européenne belle qui signifie brion
le suffixe noces indique une divinité
des les noces et le brillant divin
sur certaines inscriptions belenos ou
apollon est associé au nom ma peau noces
comme à chamalières en auvergne ou dans
l'abbaye de exams au nord-est de
l'angleterre
en gaulois et ambri tonique ma peau veut
dire fils c'est l'équivalent de mac en
irlande est ainsi ma peau noces et le
fils divin
c'est sans doute ce divine enfants de
lumière belenos ma peau noces qui sur
monster gauloise et figurer dans les
bras des trois matre les déesses du
destin
il n'est de la vierge qui doit enfanter
cette vierge que l'on a ensuite associé
à marie dans les églises de chartres
longpont sur orge et nogent sous coucy
d'une certaine façon c'est donc leur
propre dieu de lumière que les celtes
ont d'abord reconnu dans le fils et
l'est de la vierge marie jésus-christ
l'ancien prophétie des druides va
bientôt se fondre avec le culte solaire
de l' empire et l'évangile des chrétiens
ces étapes sont essentiels pour saisir
comment une civilisation a changé de nom
de religion tout en gardant la même
croyance
au ivème siècle des druides officiait
encore en gaule est long et honorer un
héros solaire et guérisseurs enfants
divin né d'une vierge
en occident le christianisme est
beaucoup plus apaisé camps n'ont rien
à quelques exceptions près golez
bretagne ont été épargnés par les grande
persécution
par syncrétisme pagano chrétiens les
terres celtique porte donc en germe
l'émergence du christ en tant que dieu
céleste et lumineux
[Musique]
l'empereur constantin a reçu une
formation militaire
c'est un guerrier émérite mais c'est
aussi un mystique
comme toute sa génération il se cherche
un dieu
[Musique]
l'un des panégyriques de constanta e
mail douteux rapporte qu'en 310
constantin se trouvait en gaule dans un
sanctuaire druidique consacré à apollon
belenos
le lieu n'est pas précisé mais il s'agit
dixit du plus beau temple du monde
la saisie d'une vision surnaturel
constantin voit son dieu apollon
[Musique]
7-0 fanny du dieu soleil lui annonce la
victoire à la guerre et l' empire du
monde
certaines références utilisées par
humaines sont celtique tel l'allusion au
fameux cycle gaulois de trente années
ainsi indispose à la fortune que tes
succès te rappelle en ces lieux le voeu
que tu avais fait aux dieux immortels
quand tu avais des tours n'était pas
vers le plus beau temple du monde et
même comme tu as vu vers le dieu en
personne car tu as vu je crois aux
constantes un ton apollon accompagné de
la victoire d'offrir des couronnes de
lauriers dont chacune apporte le présage
de trente années tel est en effet le
comptage de siècle d'hommes qui a toi en
tout cas doivent une vieillesse au delà
de celle de nestor et que dis-je je
crois tu as vu et ut reconnu dans ce
visage dans celui que récitent les
champs divin des prophètes est acquis et
du le royaume du monde
cette révélation divine prédit que les
temps sont accomplis
le destin appel constantin a gouverné
lempire sous la houlette d'apollon
mais eux-mêmes prend soin de dédoubler
le dieu il vient de dire à constanta ton
apollon
mais il ajoute ensuite notre apollo
référence au dieu solaire national
moi je pense que c'est en train
d'arriver puisque tu es comme lui un
jeune heureux salutaire et belle
empereur désormais tous ces temples de
réclames me semble-t-il et surtout notre
apollon dont les eaux bouillantes
punissent les parjures qui doivent être
particulièrement odieux
chez les celtes le dieu de lumière est
au coeur de la religion sur les collines
il porte le nom de l'udc
dans les eaux thermales il porte le nom
de belenos
cette première vision du dieu solaire
dans un sanctuaire druidique a
bouleversé constantin l'homme
l'empereur va maintenant avoir une
seconde vision céleste et public prélude
aux bouleversements de l'empiré du monde
en
312 l'occident est divisée en deux
factions
constantin règne sur la gaule et la
bretagne
maxence sur rome l'italie et l'afrique
un conflit décisif se prépare
les préparatifs sont autant militaire
que culturel comme beaucoup dans son
armée constantin vénère le dieu unique
mais il ne sait pas à quoi de concret
rattacher ce dieu
il lui faudrait un signe une présence
visible et si possible public que tous
lui et ses hommes partagent ensuite la
même foi et soit à l'unisson dans les
combats
un jour alors qu'il fait soleil
constanta et ses soldats assistent à un
événement mystérieux dans le ciel tout
s'aperçoivent près du soleil une croix
brillante et comme souligné d'une
inscription c'est le signe tant attendu
le lieu de l'apparition n'est pas
précisée dans les textes mais une
tradition locale rapporte que cela se
serait passé dans un village de la
bresse du nom de sainte croix
oz de césarée évêques en palestine et
amis de constantin raconte dans la
biographie qu'il a consacrée à
l'empereur ce témoignage qu'il tient de
lui en personne
il affirmait avoir vu de ses yeux dans
le ciel surmontant et accompagnant le
soleil une croix le lumière avec un
texte qui disait par se situe vaincra et
qu'il avait été forte émerveillée de ce
spectacle lui et son armée
la nuit suivante constantin fait un
songe
il voit le christ lui présenter la même
croix de lumière que celle qui l'a vu
rayonner dans le ciel
et dieu ordonne à l'empereur de façonner
pour son armée un étendard avec ce
symbole qui lui vaudra victoire dans
tous ses combats
[Musique]
l'acte ans est un intellectuel chrétien
d'origine berbère son témoignage
complète celui de zeb
durant son sommeil constante à vue
avertit de marquer le signes célestes de
dieu sur les boucliers et d'engager
ensuite le combat se conformant aux
ordres il marque le christ sur les
boucliers par une croix surmontée d'un
arrondi de part et d'autre
obéissant à dieu constantin commandes de
peindre ce symbole sacré sur les
boucliers de ses soldats
cette mystérieuse croient a été
diversement interprétée toujours dans un
sens chrétien et selon l'alphabet grec
soit comme un qui la lettre initiale du
mot christ soit comme la réunion des
initiales de jésus-christ qui est iota
soit comme la réunion des deux premières
lettres du mot christ qui est au
constantin on a montré la figure a à z
de césarée qui en donne une description
assez complexe
c'est une haute lance couverte d'or qui
porte une corne en oblique à la manière
d'une croix au dessus sur le sommet une
couronne de pierres précieuses et d'or a
été frappée à l'intérieur c'est
l'emblème du sauveur indiqué par les
deux premières lettres du nom du christ
l'euro baran lucky par le milieu
ce signe chrétiens se nomme le lab à
rome
toutefois ces postérieurement aux
événements que le la baronne a été
réinterprétée et plus ou moins à ranger
dans une optique chrétienne au départ il
s'agit d'un symbole payen
le nom du la barre homme tire sa source
du gaulois la barre haut qui signifie
parole éloquence dans le ciel c'est la
voix de dieu pour paraphraser saint jean
c'est le verbe divin
le la barre sommes aperçus en gaule
pourrait être la résonance d'un très
vieux symbole druidique la roue de
taranis
l'ancien dieu gaulois du tonnerre en
effet tronet jadis dans le ciel avec
sarrois plusieurs rayons ce même ciel de
gaulle où le lab à rome vient de se
manifester devant constantin et c'est
léger
à l'aube de ce 4ème siècle encore très
payen des celtes de l'armée de
constantin concert sans doute sur eux
comme un talisman ce signe familier
d'origine druidique peut-être même
certains soldats à rebours t-il déjà sur
leur bouclier le fameux la baronne il
aura suffi que par la suite des
intellectuels chrétiens hillis de bonne
foi le monogramme du christ pour que
l'emblème de taranis deviennent
l'emblème du sauveur
l'historien de la religion gauloise
jean-jacques at présente ainsi l'origine
de la barre sommes chrétiens
mais c'est le signe de taranis la roue à
quatre rayons qui après avoir été vu par
constantin devient le premier symbole du
lab à rome pour être dans la suite
interprété en christ par les chrétiens
de rome entré en contact avec l'empereur
tant qu il est vrai que pour les gaulois
de l'armée de constantin s'était encore
au 4e siècle taranis qui détenait le
pouvoir militaire et la faculté de
vaincre l'ennemi et par là même de
protéger l'empereur et l' empire
en tant que roux céleste le lab à rome
s'apparentent plus ou moins au soleil
parés de ce signe celtique et solaire
d'invincibilité le pieux constantin
gagne alors l'italie
[Musique]
le 28 octobre 312 il remporte à rome la
bataille décisive du pont milvius
l'usurpateur maxence et vaincus
la date de conversion de constantin au
christianisme n'est pas assurée
certains la situe en 312 d'autres plus
tard voir sur son lit de mort
preuve de son attachement au christ
constantin promulguée 313 l'édit de
milan dont la tolérance vise surtout à
protéger les chrétiens de toute
persécution
on aurait toutefois tort de croire que
l'empereur a renoncé au paganisme
constantin demeurent autant disciples du
soleil que du christ ainsi sur les
monnaies de l' empire c'est aux côtés du
soleil qu'on le voit figurer
le dieu du soleil et même à ce point à
l'honneur qu'un jour particulier de la
semaine lui sera désormais consacrée
c'est à constanta que l'on doit la loi
qui en 321 fait du dimanche le jour du
soleil invaincu
à l'instar de ses légions gauloise
constantin croient au dieu unique ils on
reconnaît la sainte figure dans le
soleil et dans le christ et il en
affiche là cinq puissances par le la
baronne des celtes
[Musique]
la quête de constanta et celle de son
siècle les divers paganisme apparaissent
alors comme des religions incomplète
avec les années il devient clair que ce
seigneur céleste qui communique avec les
hommes ne peut être que le dieu incarné
jésus-christ fils de la sainte vierge
dans un esprit de synthèse en voie
d'achèvement le christianisme dépasse
les mythologies nationale résout les
dilemmes philosophique et accomplit les
promesses divines